こんにちはー
はぁっ社長でそういうわけで今日行ってまいりました
地味に好評の文房具脳なんです結構分道具好きの方が多くてすごい正直嬉しいです結局
は学生は学生低下結局はね
書くことは音一音良いてすごい大事なことなんでペンっていうのはとても大事なんです
よ
はい
伊達最高
シャープで最高って言いました今ジョイント今日紹介するのはコチラのおレンズです
寄付コメントでもありましたよねこれぜひ紹介してください的な
もうねぇ瓜系の店とがあって結構探すの大変だったけど頑張って見つけました
新乱射さが0.2ということでマジで国補そうなんですよ
すぎなほど芯が折れない
パイプが神はサポートする
コツは500円ですよねえっ疹が出ていない状態
なんで書けるのじゃあ本当にこんなに欠けるんでしょうか
0.2で芯を出さずにかけるって書いてあります
これは500円ですちょっと最近のシャーペン高い一ねー
ちょっと
おおすごいすごくはないか
まず0.2って目調れるイメージがあるんですよけど俺ないっていう
だから名前ガオレンズって言うらしいですパイプが出ていて芯が出ていない状態にして
くださいこっそ
これじゃバック
うん
本をすげー
家にでちょっとカモンカメラ5は説明書によると疹が出ていない状態で
かけってことらしいです今これ疹が出ていない状態なんですけど実際に
かけるんですよじゃあ細いから書きやすいっすよこれ
これはアリですわ炭に本体はこんな感じでグループがちょっとここしまってっ
そそってなったらすごくあんまり細いシャーペンあまり好まないんですけどけどやっぱ
0.2っていうのは本当に本なんか小さい字書きたい女子が多いじゃないですかこんな
こんな次会でこうなんか可愛らしい組説するこのぶりっこ系の女子
ドジャー
0.2っていうのはとても良いんじゃないでしょうか
car
シャー芯はどうやって買えばいいんだろうってくらいちょっと特殊なシャーペンなんて
ぜひ皆さんお店でお買い求めください
true
5は色のバリエーションは白黒黄色ピンクスカイブルーの5色らしいです
これはヤバイですよフィア